if you're looking for a mattress go with
helix sleep their two-minute sleep quiz
will tell you which mattress is perfect
for you you'll get up to 200 off and two
free pillows at
helixsleep.com pacman
welcome to the show everybody lots of
big news to talk about including some
really important um pharmaceutical
developments as we might call them merck
is now pushing into the emergency use
authorization request phase a so-called
coveted pill
that
they say based on their trials reduces
the risk of hospitalization and death
by about 50 percent now my view on this
has been that politics aside having an
effective treatment
in addition to a vaccine is a really
great thing there's a lot of people
thinking about this in the context of
the unvaccinated well now the
unvaccinated don't have to worry because
they can take a pill if they get the
virus and it cuts risk of
hospitalization and death by fifty
percent there may be people that are
going to think about it that way uh but
not me let's talk about um the
developments and then we will go from
there merck says covet pill
cuts risk of death and hospitalization
in a potential leap forward in the
global fight against the pandemic drug
maker merck
said friday
that its experimental pill for people
sick with covet reduced hospitalizations
and deaths by half
if cleared by regulators it would be the
first pill shown to treat covid19 adding
a whole new easy-to-use weapon
to an arsenal that already includes the
vaccine the company said it will soon
ask health officials in the u.s and
around the world to authorize the pill's
use a decision from the u.s food and
drug administration could come within
weeks after that all other covid
treatments authorized in the u.s require
an iv or an injection
a pill taken at home by contrast would
ease pressure pressure on hospitals and
could also help curb outbreaks in poorer
and more remote corners of the world
that don't have access to the more
expensive infusion therapies this would
allow us to treat many more people much
more quickly and we trust much less
expensively
merck and its partner ridgeback
biotherapeutics as early said early
results showed patients who received the
drug
malnopiravir within five days of covet
symptoms had about half the rate of
hospitalization and death as those who
received a dummy pill the placebo the
study tracked 775 adults with mild to
moderate covid considered high risk for
disease because of health problems like
obesity diabetes or heart disease the
results have not yet been reviewed by
outside experts
the usual procedure for vetting new
medical research among patients taking
malnupiravir 7.3 were either
hospitalized or died at the end of 30
days compared with 14 percent of those
getting the dummy pill that is a
significant reduction
after that time period there were no
deaths among those who received the drug
compared with eight deaths in the
placebo group this is one of those cases
we've talked about before medical ethics
when the test uh
medication or procedure
seems to be working so well it becomes
unethical to keep people on the placebo
and in fact that's what they talk about
here
um the results were so strong that an
independent group of medical experts
monitoring the trial recommended
stopping it early executives plan to
submit data to the fda in the coming
days
and experts stress the importance of
getting vaccinated anyway so again a lot
of people hearing this and saying we've
been saying there's going to be a
treatment of some kind we don't need to
get vaccinated that's not at all what
this is about
my thinking is the following math
this is a great additional layer in in
addition to vaccination we've talked so
much about you know i did what was
available to me i went and got the
vaccine
and yet it's not a hundred percent no
vaccine is 100
and immunity may wane as is often the
case with vaccines we're trying to
figure out to what degree and how how
much and how much in relation to uh the
mutations of the coronavirus but we've
done all those things and yet we could
still get it and we could get really
sick and we could die so what do you do
well here we have something that's an
additional barrier it's not something to
justify getting no vaccine imagine that
your risk of death is 90 percent lower
with the vaccine so okay let's say the
overall
infection fatality rate of covet is 0.8
why are we saying 0.8 well officially is
1.6
but we have reason to believe that the
real number of infections is actually
two or even up to three times
the number of cases that are officially
known so that would put the infection
fatality rate in reality somewhere
between 0.4 and 0.8 let's call it 0.8
okay so i get the vaccine these are
rough numbers i get the vaccine and
let's say that reduces risk of death by
90 percent
i've gone now risk of death wise from
0.8
to 0.08
i've reduced my risk of death
dramatically on an infection basis
if this pill then cuts it by 50
you're talking about vaccine plus having
the covet pill if you get sick as two
things together that would drop your
risk of death to
0.04 percent now for the unvaccinated it
also cuts it but it remains 10 times
higher if you if you eliminate the
vaccine
layer of protection
the risk of death is 0.8 percent
if you get sick you take the pill that
drops it drops it to 0.4 percent me
i would prefer
0.04
as my risk of death rather than 0.4
that's just me you could do the
calculations you want but that's
sounding pretty good to me so this will
be submitted for emergency use um and by
the way i i'm going gonna get ahead of
one thing
there are tons of anti-vaxxers who have
been saying i'm not taking an
experimental vaccine
who are already saying look the covet
pill we knew it was coming i don't need
the vaccine because of the covet pill
this is just as experimental in the
sense that it doesn't yet even have
emergency use authorization
if it gets it it will have the status
the vaccines have had for a year
only a month ago or so roughly
was the pfizer vaccine actually fully
approved so if your reason all along for
not taking the vaccine was it's
experimental in the sense that it's eua
emergency use approved
the best case scenario for the coveted
pill that you might use to justify not
getting a vaccine is that it would have
that same emergency use authorization
status so these people are pathetic we
know that this to me is not an
alternative to vaccination it's if you
get vaccinated and you unfortunately get
sick anyway which is not super likely
right now but it does happen
statistically not super likely most of
the infections are in the unvaccinated
um
you have another layer of protection and
that's a really really good thing
we've been talking about when in the
covid pandemic does it become a
republican virus in the united states
why would it become a republican virus
well three reasons number one
republicans are far less willing to get
vaccinated than everybody else number
two republicans are less willing to wear
masks than everybody else and number
three republicans are less willing to
accept and participate in other sorts of
precautions uh physical distancing
reducing crowd sizes
provisions in schools etc than others so
over time we would think this might
become a republican pandemic in the
united states you look at republican
governors
republican governors are much less
likely to require vaccines uh or to go
with vaccine requirements in their
states and two they're much less likely
to put in place mass or to support mass
mandates in their states and to support
other precautions so we've been saying
for months
to some degree it's probably already a
republican virus in the united states
more so than anything else based on
those numbers and now we have the proof
the new york times just released a map
of the covet death rate
since june 16. so this is roughly the
last hundred thousand hundred and twenty
thousand deaths deaths from june 16
forward june july august september okay
it looks like a map of republican voters
we have that we have the map up on the
screen the map that we have on the
screen could be a map of where people
voted for donald trump most heavily it's
actually a map of where
we've seen the highest per capita covet
death rates over the last 100 or 120 000
deaths and in fact we can put up on the
screen
side by side the map of the last hundred
thousand deaths per capita uh hundred
thousand deaths on a per capita basis on
the left and on the right a map that
shows um support for donald trump versus
joe biden by blue and red dots now i
know that a ton of people will say hold
on a second david well whoa whoa hold on
sir
the states with the most per capita
deaths
are blue states remember it's new york
it's new jersey it's massachusetts for a
little while it was california first of
all that's no longer true so
that might have been true seven months
ago if you now look at the top 15 states
by per capita death rate today
you'll see that now it's a ton of red
states the reddest mississippi has the
highest per capita death rate
new jersey's still there then you've got
louisiana alabama
florida arkansas georgia south carolina
south dakota indiana it's more and more
red states what happened
what happened is exactly what we've been
predicting from day one early before we
knew anything about the virus when it
was too early to know what to do this
was a new pandemic the places that had
the bad luck to be early infected places
did the worst by far these were places
that were connected by direct flights to
china and to the parts of europe that
had early spread like italy and a few
other countries so overwhelmingly that
meant the big airport gateways on the
east coast new york and boston at one
point it was calif california to some
degree
illinois with chicago airport and so
many united and american airlines
flights to the the places with the early
spread those are all blue states blue
cities
but over time as we learn more about how
do you suppress spread what doesn't
doesn't work we saw blue states get more
vaccinated than red states we saw blue
states wear more mat and wear more masks
and the like we expected that the deaths
would start to move over to red states
on a per capita basis once the virus was
everywhere
rather than the chance of what places
had the flights to china and italy early
on
we expected the deaths would shift to
the places that are not getting
vaccinated and are not wearing masks and
that has now happened plain and simple
the last 100 000 deaths have been most
heavy as you can see on the map
in florida georgia south carolina
alabama mississippi louisiana arkansas
missouri texas you get the picture so
there's nothing surprising here
the shock is
how political the deaths have gotten now
of course liberals in red states are
dying too
of course conservatives and blue states
are dying too
but this is the trend this should really
scare the republican party not because
they care about people dying i don't
know if they do maybe they do maybe they
don't they don't seem to but maybe they
do but this should scare the republican
party because it can't be good for
winning elections to see your voters
disproportionately be the ones dying
from a pandemic that you are failing to
do the things that public health experts
say should be done in order to control
it
it's not possible to miss when you look
at that map
how the deaths the last hundred thousand
hundred and twenty thousand deaths are
aligning with voting trends vaccination
against a hundred year pandemic virus
is now a test of political allegiance it
is an incredible thing
um and unfortunately
it seems like this is going to be the
trend for some period of time cases
continue to decline that'll benefit
everybody
uh but it seems like it is really not
good in many of these red states and i
guess i was naive i thought something
like this might actually cross party
lines and people would just come
together and listen to public health
experts and doctors but uh no i i was
wrong again i was the naive buffoon hey
listen um on october 19th tuesday
october 19th we're doing something very
special we are doing a live town hall
this will be exclusively on the new
david pakman show youtube channel on the
second channel called pacman live
6 p.m east 3 p.m west on tuesday october
19th we will be doing a live town hall
all questions will be open
members will get priority in the queue
to talk to me and to ask questions this
will not be on the main youtube channel
this will not be on twitch or twitch as
some people call it it will not be on
facebook this will be on the pacman live
youtube channel find it
at youtube.com pacmanlive
or davidpakman.com pacman live they both
go to the same place
mark it in your calendar tuesday october
19 6 pm
exclusive pacman live only town hall
and in the meantime
always you can let me know what kind of
crazy high junks people are up to with
masks and vaccines in your state
by finding me on twitter at dpakman
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows for free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video all right we're going to talk
in this segment about a democratic
senator kirsten cinema and we're going
to talk about democratic senator joe
manchin these will be two different
stories each of them up to their own
fair bit of hijinks now as you may know
and as we've been talking about for some
time
it is not merely theoretical that joe
manchin and kirsten cinema
may become obstacles to this slimmest of
majorities in the senate for democrats
to become legislation it has become very
very clear that both cinema and mansion
listen whether they enjoy it or not
that's speculation i think that they do
whether they enjoy it or not they are
obstacles to democrats getting things
done and right now what's in focus is
joe biden's build back better agenda as
as it is called
large amounts of infrastructure spending
budgetary issues and on and on and on
and these questions as to whether
kirsten cinema or joe manchin and or joe
manchin are going to support what is
going on here and increasingly they are
getting in the way
so let's first talk about kirsten cinema
kirsten cinema
was followed into a bathroom
um
by uh activists filming her during an
event over the weekend and i'm gonna
give you i got a ton of questions about
this david what do you think what do you
think about this is this okay is this
not let's talk about the story first
watch the video and then we will kind of
decide a video posted to twitter on
sunday by social justice group living
united for change in arizona shows youth
organizers confronting senator kirsten
cinema even following her into a
bathroom at one point
looking to talk to the democratic
representative about her opposition to
the build back better agenda president
biden's ambitious economic recovery plan
widely supported by democrats several
activists can be seen in the video
waiting outside what lucha that's the
abbreviation for the the acronym for the
group said was cinema's classroom on
arizona state university's campus when
cinema emerges they asked to speak to
her actually i'm heading out she replies
and walks into a bathroom stall over the
sound of toilets flushing an activist
identified as blanca spoke to cinema
from the entrance saying we have to hold
you accountable in another video
by lucha the protesters follow cinema as
she walks back into her classroom they
said we wouldn't have to resort to
confronting cinema around phoenix if she
took meetings with the communities that
elected her
cinema's communication director declined
to comment telling the daily beast we
are not dignifying this behavior with a
response so let's take a look at the
video okay uh and let's listen this is
uh senator cinema heading into the
bathroom followed in by activists
okay i'll be back
today we want to talk to you real quick
can we talk to you okay actually i am
heading out
but um right now is a real moment that
our people need in order for us to be
able to talk about what's really
happening yeah we need a buildback
better plan right now
we we're not gonna
we knocked on doors for you to get you
elected and just how we got you elected
we can get you out of office if you
don't support what you promised
us we need seven million citizenship for
seven million we need the
benefit right now
so now the toilet plug my name is lanka
i was brought here to the united states
when i was three years old and in 2010
my grandparents both got deported
because of sb 1070
and i'm here because i definitely
believe that we need a pathway to
citizenship my grandfather passed away
two weeks ago and i was not able to go
to mexico and visit him because there is
no pathway to citizenship and if we have
the opportunity to pass it right now
then we need to do it because there's
millions of undocumented people just
like me who share the same story or even
worse things that happen to them because
of sb 1070 and because of anti-immigrant
legislation and this is opportunity to
pass it right now and we need you to we
need to hold you accountable to what you
told us what you promised us that you
were going to pass when we knocked on
doors for you it's not right
i'm a survivor
and a survivor of human trafficking and
it's because of the lack of work okay
so i think you generally understand uh
what uh what went down there so okay
um
we've got our issues with senator cinema
uh some are saying david following
someone into a bathroom it's bad it's
cringy it's an absolute disaster the
counterpoint that i've seen is she
wasn't really going to the bathroom she
was just going to the bathroom because
she assumed that she would be able to
get away from the activists
uh and those were fake flushes they were
not necessary flushes i don't know the
answer to that okay i i might where i
come down on this is as follows
it's hard to predict what kind of
activism will get results and there's
this common trope of trying to control
activism by saying this is off-limits
that's off-limits and so like for
example sometimes when people show up to
the house of a senator they don't go in
they don't go on the lawn they don't go
in the house but they're on the sidewalk
with a loud speaker saying senator
whatever vote for this vote for that and
there will be people who say no that's
that's over the line
i don't want to be the one saying if
we're not breaking the law and we're not
doing violence
i'm not
feeling super comfortable like i'm the
person to say what types of active
activism are okay or not because if we
only ever did the activism that's
comfortable for those in power literally
nothing would ever change okay so i'm
not making like a big statement about
what is and is not allowed because i
just don't think i need to i'm not the
pro there's probably other people that
are willing to give you the list
my view is i don't think this is going
to achieve anything that's how i feel
about this specific incident um and
basically you know my bill share
sarcastically tweeted yesterday i think
it was
alongside this video
we're definitely getting the 3.5
trillion now
i just don't think that this will work
and remember also that if you are cinema
it's arizonans who voted for you and as
bill share also tweeted
cinema may be widely loathed on twitter
but not so in arizona the most recent
arizona poll has her favorable
unfavorable at 46.39
not amazing but her net favorability is
three points higher than mark kelly also
in arizona and her unfavorability is
four points lower her unfavorability
among democrats is 19 points higher
but favorable unfavorable with democrats
is still a net positive now you could
make the case well but it's mostly
democrats who vote so it still leaves
her
liable to a primary challenge oh
challenger right without a doubt i mean
that's that's absolutely fine
i think the point here is
even though there are conflicting polls
and she's loathed on twitter
um she probably has a kind of okay
popularity level among the people that
vote for her which three years before
reelection
is probably fine so the idea that she's
just completely tanking in front of the
people that elected her doesn't really
seem to be supported by the numbers the
point is what she's been doing i hate it
i think that this is absolutely a
disaster
it's just not been a disaster to date
with her own constituents and so is it
wrong to follow her into a bathroom
i don't think it's going to work to
actually achieve anything is the way
that i would say it
um
i wouldn't follow people into a bathroom
and i get that some are saying she just
went in there
on that basis the idea was that she
could hide out
maybe i don't know
i don't see this as really changing
anything but i do
agree with myself from nine months ago
saying this mansion cinema stuff is
really going to become a problem i want
to talk about joe manchin next
joe manchin
as much as or more than kirsten cinema
has become an obstacle
to joe biden's agenda there's really no
other way to say it
and i think he's enjoying it he seems to
love going on the sunday shows he seems
to love having the amount of power that
he has because of this razor thin
majority 50 50 with kamala harris as the
tiebreaking vote in the senate
well if you can imagine anything more
uh privileged i don't really know what
to call it over the weekend
senator manchin emerged from his yacht
called the almost heaven
to have some real conversations with
west virginia's who kayaked out to his
yacht
every single day of the week
um this is just depressing on so many
levels let's take a listen this is joe
manchin talking to west virginians from
his yacht let me talk if you can where
are you all from
anybody from west virginia west virginia
we have a lot of west virginians
god bless you all
but gang we're working hard we really
are we're going to continue to in good
faith i really you want to get a good
bill that's a balanced bill that's well
done
and i know it won't be enough for some
it'll be too much for others in west
virginia
you know west virginia is a little bit
different than it used to be
there's a lot of poverty
what are you going to do for the poor in
west virginia i think we're going to be
working everything we can to create good
opportunities and we need to tax the
rich
oh i agree with that i definitely agree
that's the one number thing we should be
doing is fixing the tax codes everybody
pays their fair share
we should be also negotiating for lower
drug prices we should be doing all these
things
accountable i agree with you one
thousand percent we're on the same page
gang we really are
i in my yacht and you on your kayaks
even though i'm getting in the way of
all these bills we really are on the
same page
that's a real opportunity that we can do
well
here let me just explain on that one we
will get to that eventually but right
now we can't even take care it's going
to go broke in 2026. let us fix it up
first that's not true
we're taxing the rich i agree we're
going to make the rich in the famous bay
all right so as you can tell the the
conversation's not really going too too
far but of course the imagery of joe
manchin is the guy standing in the way
not only
generally
of an infrastructure bill and a spending
bill as big as what many democrats and
joe biden want it's not just that joe
manchin is generally standing in the way
joe manchin is standing in the way
of west virginians who were his
constituents from getting that who so
desperately need it
and talking about it from the back of
his yacht okay that you can't have more
insidious imagery than this and i hate
to say this west virginia is a disaster
i i'm not going after the people of west
virginia what i'm telling you is
west virginia
needs this
west virginia is ranked 47th out of 50
in healthcare in terms of access quality
and public health 47 out of 50. 50 is
the worst not the best just to be clear
west virginia is ranked 45th out of 50
in terms of education as far as higher
ed
and pre-k through 12 are concerned
as far as infrastructure west virginia
is dead last 50th out of 50 american
states that's based on energy
internet access and transportation so i
could go on and on
but the point is that west virginia is
one of the states that most desperately
needs this spending spending education
health care
and hilariously or maybe not hilariously
maybe it's more a tragedy
west virginia is one of the biggest
takers
if states
had welfare queens it's not a term that
i actually believe in you know it has
it's an old trope from reagan but in any
case if states had welfare queens west
virginia is one of the biggest welfare
queens west virginia is the fifth most
dependent state
on money from the federal government big
strong independent
no actually they are highly dependent on
federal money and this is the guy that
they have
from his yacht
saying oh we don't need to do that yet
and maybe we'll get to this or maybe
maybe we will get to that
west virginia is not well served by joe
manchin the country is not well served
by joe manchin but yet i'm not going to
forget the reality you all know that i'm
also a pragmatist
if you primary joe manchin with bernie
and somehow bernie wins among democrats
in west virginia
then you get a republican in that seat
and so we can we are in this conundrum
and i continue to believe really the
path forward is if mansion has to if
mansion's the democrat that we can get
in west virginia then there need to be
other seats won from other states that
are more moderate um
uh sure taking all of the above approach
i'm not saying don't do that uh but we
we often end up in that uh conundrum
we're gonna have more of this clip of uh
mansion addressing
the peons from his yacht
on our instagram you can find us at
david pakman show on instagram find me
on instagram david.pacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpackman.com
things are really not going well for
many of the people who worked for donald
trump but specifically for many of those
people who
uh attempted to
prosecute the
voter fraud that they
claimed took place during the november
of 2020 election we're going to talk
about sydney powell in a moment but
first i want to start with rudy giuliani
we wondered for a while
where did the bogus stories about the
2020 election come from like we we
understand who was spreading them it was
rudy
steve bannon trump himself sydney powell
jenna ellis fox news newsmax oh yeah
like we know who who was spreading them
but where did a lot of this stuff
surface from about
massive dumps of ballots and the wrong
amount of food being brought to
overnight workers and the
water main break being fake you know
like all this who came up with it
originally there was a total lack of
evidence for it
wasn't subjected to any real rigorous
probing it was just repeated but where
did it come from
and at least as far as rudy giuliani is
now admitting under oath
at least some of it was just stuff he
saw on social media it's that
humiliating it's that pathetic it's that
embarrassing so let's take a look at
this report
business insider rudy giuliani admits
under oath that he got some of his
evidence of alleged election fraud from
social media
rudy giuliani admitted under oath that
his evidence of voter fraud in the 2020
election in uh came partly from social
media and that he did not interview or
fact check his sources
donald trump's former personal lawyer
made the comments in a deposition on
august 14 in relation to a defamation
lawsuit brought by a former dominion
voting systems employee
eric coomer first published by the
colorado sun coomer is suing the trump
campaign and others for promoting
baseless conspiracy theories that he
helped quote rig the election for joe
biden in the deposition
giuliani admitted that he got some of
his information about coomer's alleged
role in the fraud
from his social media posts
but couldn't be sure if it was facebook
or another platform
those social media posts get all one to
me
when questioned about whether he saw any
other evidence linking coomer with
election fraud he responded right now i
can't recall anything else i laid eyes
on
the conspiracy theories about coomer
were sparked by accusations made by
right wing podcast host joe altman
altman claimed to have infiltrated an
antifa conference call in which someone
who identified themselves as eric from
dominion
boasted about preventing trump from
winning the election according to the
new york times altman offered no proof
of his claims
the podcast host then found eric
coomer's facebook profile on which he
had supposedly written anti-trump
messages
rudy and other trump allies seized upon
altman's allegations repeating them in
the now in infamous november 19 press
conference
one of the smartmatic patent holders
eric coomer i believe his name is is on
the web as being recorded in a
conversation with antifa members
saying that he had the election rigged
for mr biden
um according to court papers giuliani
spent virtually no time investigating
the claims this is great giuliani said
he was too busy when asked why he
repeated those claims without verifying
them giuliani said in the deposition
it's not my job in a fast-moving case to
go out and investigate every piece of
evidence that's given to me why wouldn't
i believe him i would have to have been
a terrible lawyer gee
let's go find out if it's untrue i
didn't have time to go do that
uh
trump has totally abandoned rudy as far
as we can tell
so there's really no advantage to rudy
lying in this deposition right his
reputation's in shambles
his finances are eroding away he might
as well tell the truth under oath
and he is telling the truth here i
believe you know we joke about people's
research they say they've researched the
vaccine they've researched the election
it's not his job to investigate pieces
of evidence which he later cites and
presents in court
and this is a lawyer
who actually is materially involved in
this stuff so when your cousin's
sister's
cashier at the local
job lot
says i've researched the vaccine
um
understand what they mean by research
and understand even rudy here saying i
mean i'm just pro i'm i'm bringing this
stuff to courts i don't have time to
actually see if what i'm saying is true
this is one of the biggest lies
perpetuated by right-wing media for
nearly the last year and some of the
stuff started just something rudy saw on
social media he had every tool at his
disposal but he went with what sounded
the wildest and most egregious that he
came across on his computer or his phone
and also remember rudy wanted 20 grand a
day from trump to push all of this stuff
on the basis partially
of stuff he saw on social media
funny though
imagine that
he's lying about where he got it like i
think he's telling the truth but imagine
if saying that it's from social media
was to cover up where he really got it
and it's like somewhere even worse i
don't even know where that would be
uh but i do believe that rudy finally is
telling the truth trump's abandoned him
his finances are a problem i can't think
of any reason that he would lie now
um and this is where the stuff came from
it came from social media
well it's been a long tough road for
the uh delusional unhinged trump fraud
lawyer sydney powell
but it does seem as though her story has
peaked and now we are we're really in
the danuman as i like to say this might
be the last piece of the story as sydney
powell has now reportedly been banned
from all of donald trump's properties
recall that she's been a beleaguered
attorney for a while now um early on in
the 2020 voter fraud lies she was very
involved she appeared at that
mind-blowing press conference where rudy
giuliani's hair dye melted all over his
face and that's the one where she made
the wild claims about hugo chavez
antifa
cuba some guy named eric coomer and many
others
at some point sydney powell clearly was
working with donald trump but soon after
that outrageous press conference the
trump campaign put out a statement
saying sydney powell is working on her
own
trying to create distance because what
she did was so humiliating but then she
showed up at the oval office so it
really wasn't clear what was taking
place well now she's been totally
disgraced we've covered some of the
really embarrassing interviews that she
gave in the last few months her cohort
rudy giuliani has been sanctioned by
various bar associations trump has
seemingly abandoned both giuliani and
sydney powell
but now to add insult to injury powell
is reportedly on trump's so-called no-go
list at his properties the daily beast
reports that quote
since he left office in january certain
advisers and long-time associates to
trump have kept an informal short list
of people who they should look out for
including at trump's private clubs or
offices in florida new jersey and new
york the point of this roster is to
intercept and possibly rebuff attempted
outreach visits or phone calls from a
handful of conservative figures who
could bring the ex-president more
undesired headaches
this is expanded on further
in a daily beast article
which says
what does it say sydney is very much on
the no go list her problems right now do
not need to be the former president's
problems
powell's legal exposure right now is of
course massive and ever since she tried
to work with trump to orchestrate a coup
last year against joe biden feelings of
frustration and bitterness have lingered
between trump and powell but what that
means is
in the end trump will turn on you
in this case without you even
diminishing your support for him we know
that if you go from 110 supportive of
trump to 99 supportive trump often turns
on you anyway in this case sydney powell
seems to have made uh maintained her
loyalty
through and through she still is
repeating all the same stuff but here it
seems to be because she's so wacky that
donald trump is kind of backing off a
little bit i would imagine that sydney
powell thought she was going to get
massive rewards
and access
and fame and power for spreading the
election lies about trump and doing the
press conferences and the like she did
get fame in a sense for being completely
whacked out and disconnected from
reality
but we know what trump does when people
are no longer useful to him they might
be no longer useful to him because
they've turned on him people like
michael cohen they might be no longer
useful to him because they don't have
any more money and the election is over
like his supporters so he just tries to
fleece them out of their last pennies he
doesn't care and they might not be
useful to him because like sydney powell
they've just been ridiculed and made
fools of so much in the media that they
can't do anything for him anymore
anymore and think about sydney powell
who would hire her now for actual legal
work
i wouldn't hire her for
you know a real estate closing never
mind something like
what she was trying to do for donald
trump or anything in between quite
frankly so
not going well for sydney powell
banned from trump properties
not going well for rudy giuliani and
what there are lessons here and one of
the big big lessons seems to be
donald trump will turn on you
no matter how close no matter how much
he seems to like you he will turn on you
and even now
there are reports
we don't we don't know to what degree
they are true there are reports that the
relationship between trump and ivanka as
well as jared kushner have started to
deteriorate
because ivanka seems to think some of
the stuff trump has done over the last
few months continuing to push the voter
fraud lies is just making him look bad
which of course it is with much of the
world but his own supporters absolutely
love him for it so that's the latest
rudy if you invested in rudy's stock you
would be down right now if you invested
in sydney powell stock you would be down
even more
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow all right i've got
something really scary for you today all
right i'm gonna play some video for you
of a woman
who could be could be
your child's teacher hopefully she's not
but she could be a viewer who i won't
name sent me this video this is from
um uh a teacher
in her school district
um who did a video on youtube called a
lesson plan
and it wasn't a lesson plan it was an
explanation of why this teacher whose
name appears to be carly sue based on
the youtube channel that this has been
uploaded to this is an explanation of
why this teacher wasn't in school it was
a message to i guess her students and
the reason she wasn't in school is
because she refused to get vaccinated or
be tested for covid
um she goes on in this video to spread
all sorts of disinformation about the
vaccine viruses masks we're going to
look at a little bit and just understand
there are hundreds thousands of people
like this who are teaching your kids
right now
right now take a listen to this
hi everybody hope you're having a good
day
i
just got done walking my
my pup hans on this beautiful sunday
and i wanted to make a video because uh
you obviously can see that i'm not in
class today
right and i wanted to go over a few
things
one of those things being
explaining why i'm not there you deserve
to know where your teacher is please
first thing is i'm not sick
i've not
i don't have a cold i don't have a sore
throat i feel great
uh the reason that i'm not at school
today is because the administration has
enforced
the
jab
mandate as well as if you refuse the jab
then
they're requiring testing and
i
have a strong
a very strong
stance on that i feel
that it's unconstitutional
i
will never this is not a law professor
by the way and that there's nothing
unconstitutional so
we're starting with remember this is a
message to her students never ever ever
inject my body
with
something that is experimental
it doesn't qualify as a
real
vaccine
so she's whispering vaccine remember
that it is a vaccine
and the pfizer one has been fda approved
it's gene therapy it is not gene therapy
um
and
if you asked any of them not one person
would be able to tell you what is in
the shot uh the truth is the ingredients
are known they are listed anybody can
google this
now they she would probably say well the
ingredient list is a lie
but that's a different argument now
so
um i've done a lot of research and there
it is
there it is the holy grail of spreading
disinformation i've done research the
past two years about this and i knew it
would get to this point and i knew that
i would make this decision
i didn't know exactly how it was all
going to play out but
i just feel really bad that you guys
have to deal with it firsthand i feel
horrible that you have to
the problem is that they're having to
deal with her she's the problem
see this all play out because it's
it's painful and it's
uh okay so i'm gonna skip forward
because later in this clip i mean
there's a lot of nonsense here but then
she goes into just spreading straight up
imaginary cuckoo stuff
about um medical disinformation take a
look at this
oxygen actually kills the virus
the right to breathe the right to make
your own choices
i'm guessing this is anti-mask oxygen
kills the virus so the mask is bad
it's a free country or we thought it was
but it's not we have to fight for our
freedom and if you believe in freedom if
you believe in living free
then you got to do something about it
you got to have some courage you got to
step up and
decide what you believe is right
so just know that i'm praying for you
guys i care about you so deeply and
stand strong
okay
god wins and
just persevere finish strong we're
almost there can you imagine your kid
being taught in school by this woman uh
and there's so much we can say uh
obviously
there are probably some parents who like
this stuff
okay
it seems like a dystopian nightmare to
me that this is the woman that might be
teaching our children but there's
another thing i want to mention here
with all of these people
they all seem to have the idea they
don't they don't seem to question
that
they might have figured something out
about covid
that would change the entire pandemic
that the entire global medical community
hasn't figured out
uh they did their research on their home
computer
and have figured things out that public
health experts
epidemiologists immunologists
pulmonologists
around the world
haven't figured out
it's easy to call that merely delusional
but it's it's really a form of
incredible arrogance in a sense the the
idea that they may have done that now
discoveries happen discoveries happen
and they come from from different places
but the idea that these folks are the
ones that by doing research figured out
hey
all we got to do to get rid of covet is
don't wear masks
because oxygen kills the virus so just
put oxygen on the virus virus dies you
don't need masks you don't need a
vaccine and also
throwing in god's stuff too as well
it is delusional
it's dangerous to have these folks
teaching kids but there's a level of
arrogance as well that they may have
stumbled upon this um and this is a
major issue with social media actually
this is i've mentioned before i'm almost
done now reading the book technopoly by
neil postman
you this is a must-read book for anyone
participating in social media or news i
i think it's imperative everybody read
it
um there's this
reality that neil postman wrote about
that when you get a new technology it's
easy to say
let's make sure it's only used in these
ways but not in those ways and the truth
is once you've got a technology the
technology changes the culture in
irreversible ways
one of the ways in which the internet
high-speed internet internet on our
phones and social media have changed
culture
is that folks who don't really know
anything
now are empowered to do what they
believe is research and to believe their
opinions about anything at all are just
as valid
as uh those of uh actual experts now
we've talked about the crisis of
expertise this is not this is not the
fallacy of um uh
you know saying
uh if someone's an expert then
if the if the only reason you trust
someone is because they are claiming
expertise then that's a fallacy we're
talking about actual experts here and
this is one of the um
seemingly irreversible impacts of
widespread high-speed internet mobile
phones smartphones and social media and
this is really scary stuff and she's uh
she's teaching people she's teaching
kids although maybe not much longer i
guess we'll see hey here's another one
that's floating around
senator ron johnson
a republican from wisconsin appeared on
fox news
and said there is not an fda approved
covid vaccine in the u.s
now you might be wondering wait a second
they they just approved the pfizer
vaccine how what are you talking about
there's emergency use authorization for
jnj or janssen as some people like to
call it
for
moderna and there's a full approval for
pfizer
ron johnson says there isn't now his his
explanation is
nuts but i'll explain to you what we're
going to hear from braun johnson here
he says
what was approved was corminati
which is the vaccine that pfizer sells
in other countries
but that's not what's actually available
here now this has already been debunked
but let's listen it's right now in this
country roughly 70
75 of the country has gotten a single
shot uh just about 65
have gotten uh half vaccinated so
consider that back to that within the
natural immunity we're at herd immunity
right now joining you in this
legislation senator loomis uh senator
roger marshall uh utah senator mike lee
and uh looks like dan crenshaw's moving
something on the house side has any
democrat expressed they want to join you
no there will be all kinds of different
pieces of legislation pushing back on
this mandate but brian something else
have to tell america we do not have an
fda approved vaccine being administered
in the u.s okay now listen carefully
here the fda
you know played a bait and switch they
they approved the kominati version of
fisa drug it's not available in the u.s
they even admit it i sent them a letter
three days later going what what are you
doing what they did is they extended the
emergency use authorization for the
pfizer drug vaccine that's available in
the u.s here it is more than 30 days
later they haven't asked that very
simple question if you're saying that
the pfizer drug is the same as the
common addi why didn't you provide fda
approval on that so there's not an fda
approved drug and of course they
announced it so they could push through
these mandates so that people actually
think okay now these things are fda
approved so the first thing you have to
ask yourself is why why would they do
that what what would be the point i i'm
i'm trying to buy into the conspiracy i
guess if you believe that that's what
happened
you would believe it on the basis that
they couldn't really get the eua us
pfizer vaccine approved because
something is wrong with it so they
submitted approval for corminati which
is the pfizer vaccine in other countries
but that one's not actually now it's
just it's just a lie okay this has been
widely looked at it's been looked at
very strongly
nebraska medicine has a very specific
article addressing this question i've
heard that the fda said pfizer's coma
nati
comer nati and biontech formulas are
distinctly different in their vaccine
approval letter is that true
infectious disease pharmacist brian
alexander writes no in terms of what is
contained inside the vial of each they
are identical pfizer and biontech simply
formally branded or named their vaccine
biontech is the german biotech company
that partnered with pfizer to bring it
to market
pfizer komernati and pfizer biontech
covid19 vaccine are biologically the
same thing they are chemically the same
thing the confusion stems from this
section of the fda's vaccine info
one the licensed vaccine has the same
formulation as the eua authorized
vaccine and the products can be used
interchangeably to provide the
vaccination series without presenting
any safety or effectiveness concerns
concerns the products are legally
distinct with certain differences that
do not impact safety or effectiveness
the fda
desires to have a single combined
vaccine information sheet
a single sheet keeps things simple for
people giving the vaccine and getting it
since the branded and unbranded vials
are chemically identical despite being
legally distinct this information must
be included
um
it's it's just been debunked and it's
another one of these things that they
feed who else but the low information
fox news audience brian kill me doesn't
have the wherewithal to question it or
maybe doesn't have the interest in
questioning it but
a week ago five weeks ago this has
already been out there it's already been
debunked it's not true and again
this is another one of these things
where wow ron johnson researched it and
he found answers he he exposed something
this is like sometimes you'll see a post
on facebook
um and it'll say something like uh
hey you know what
uh kovit doesn't like
beet juice
and you know all you gotta do is drink
beet juice every day and you're gonna be
fine i've been drinking beet juice since
the start of the pandemic i haven't
gotten it it's like wow they missed
everything uh is it airborne versus
droplet and does it
where is the infection happening and
indoors
they won't tell you that beet juice
kills it
there are medical discoveries medical
discoveries happen and sometimes they
are they are counterintuitive or
whatever the case may be but the
arrogance with which some of these folks
present the findings
of their quote research is really
something to explore sociologically and
psychologically hey we have a voicemail
line and often the voicemails are just
disgusting i have one of the nicest
voicemails i've ever received to play
for you today
you can call the voicemail line anytime
2192davidp
call anytime you want here is just a
beautiful voicemail in a sea of insults
and ad hominems
hi uh
i just wanted to say that i think that
you're an amazing person thank you and
i'm
really happy about how your show has
progressed over the years i've watched
it
i hope you continue to you know do what
you're doing and
stay healthy and stay who you are thank
you bye what a nice message what a truly
just nice message those really are rare
and i appreciate it but criticisms are
welcome as well
2192 david p is the number call it any
time
bonus show today okay
we're gonna dive deep into republican
redistricting plans based on the 2020
census number one it's clear from their
early plans that they are going with the
gerrymandering full speed ahead and
number two
there are even proposals to slice up
liberal cities and to put a little bit
of one liberal city in par as part of a
rural district and another part of a
liberal city and to basically try to
completely eliminate the reality that
liberal cities should be represented by
the liberal elected officials that those
liberal cities want to see representing
them so we're going to talk about all of
that on today's bonus show we are also
going to talk about a connecticut doctor
who was giving patients blank covid19
exception for exemption forms vaccine
exemption forms the doctor would sign
them and give them to patients and then
if the patient needed a vaccine
exemption for whatever reason they could
use this doctor's signature she has
surrendered her medical license now the
doctor and that's a good thing and we're
going to talk about that
how do you get access to the bonus show
you go to joinpakman.com and sign up
that's it
and then lastly
tuesday october 19
we are doing a
an exclusive viewer town hall where i
will just open the phones and take
questions from everybody
6 p.m eastern tuesday october 19th it
will be streamed exclusively on our
second youtube channel pacman live
find it at youtube.com pacmanlive
or
pacman
davidpakman.compacmanlive
whatever is easier to type either way
october 19th
tuesday
six east
three west
members get priority but we will be
opening opening up the discord lines to
everybody all right we'll talk to you on
the bonus show and see you tomorrow
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors if you're looking
for a mattress go with helix sleep their
two-minute sleep quiz will tell you
which mattress is perfect for you you'll
get up to 200 off and two free pillows
at
helixsleep.com
pacman